[SPEAKER_01]: Naked guy that's got a wand.
[SPEAKER_00]: James' and Jude's discussion continued.
[SPEAKER_00]: Third of Wealsun.
[SPEAKER_01]: So yeah, I do have some ideas about at least where I could begin my research on the material.
[SPEAKER_01]: Can I be allowed to have it without facing the hanging?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: You're fully read in at this point.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like you to do research on how to
[SPEAKER_00]: Create it.
[SPEAKER_00]: I would like you to do research on what possibly negated it in the channel.
[SPEAKER_00]: Definitely.
[SPEAKER_00]: And bring Paul in on this.
[SPEAKER_00]: This is what Jian wants, and to be honest with you,
[SPEAKER_00]: He wants someone in his family to be able to have knowledge of the arcane in this.
[SPEAKER_00]: The yellow substance that you've seen was not created by any of the Iridian Princes.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Duke of Berghoff supplied it to us.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, shit.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so you need me to reverse engineer it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically.
[SPEAKER_00]: We have no idea how to produce this.
[SPEAKER_00]: The Duke of Berghoff...
[SPEAKER_00]: Quit supplying us with this substance twenty years ago.
[SPEAKER_00]: Twenty years ago?
[SPEAKER_01]: Twenty-five years ago.
[SPEAKER_01]: And the largest or only stores around the home.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do we have some here?
[SPEAKER_00]: We have a few barrels in Monmurg.
[SPEAKER_00]: The storage container, the home was created for storage and that was historically where it was.
[SPEAKER_00]: We do keep some here, however it's been used quite a bit.
[SPEAKER_00]: There is another place where it was stored and
[SPEAKER_00]: A significant store is actually located in Salinmore Bay, in between here and Saltmarsh.
[SPEAKER_00]: Is that still secure, to your knowledge?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Toli had possession of it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Like they had had possession of it, that's there.
[SPEAKER_01]: So if we needed to raid it, or did they just recently take possession of it?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's something that has rotated in possession over the years.
[SPEAKER_00]: The princes rotate their possession of all these stores.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you want us to move to seize that?
[SPEAKER_01]: Because they're going to know... Jude, at some point we need to do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: But before we do that, we need to figure out why the Toli are able to destroy ships.
[SPEAKER_00]: And this is that other thing I wanted you to look into.
[SPEAKER_00]: That artifact that Gouge was able to
[SPEAKER_00]: Trick Lord Franck into telling him about it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Did you hear of this?
[SPEAKER_00]: No.
[SPEAKER_00]: There was an agent from Keoland that came to see me last month, 15th of block time, around that time.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was talking to an alchemist
[SPEAKER_00]: In the foreign district.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think you visited him at one point.
[SPEAKER_00]: Lord Franck wished to discuss things with me and actually he was attacked by Toli agents.
[SPEAKER_01]: I did, yes, I remember.
[SPEAKER_00]: Gouge was hired by one of Franck's men to act as bodyguards.
[SPEAKER_00]: I warned them that the Toli agents were interested in what they were doing.
[SPEAKER_00]: And looking after them.
[SPEAKER_00]: What Franck, it seems, is what is known as an inquisitor.
[SPEAKER_00]: Have you ever heard of the term?
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a secret society, it's actually a government agency in Keoland called the Office of Forbidden Magic.
[SPEAKER_00]: They're a known secret, but they are sort of a...
[SPEAKER_00]: Magic policing organization that makes sure that wizards do not practice forbidden magic, such as necromancy.
[SPEAKER_00]: Some forms of conjuration.
[SPEAKER_00]: Demonic.
[SPEAKER_00]: Demonic conjuration, exactly.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably all the things that the Scarlet Brotherhood excels at.
[SPEAKER_00]: From what I understand, yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: Franck is a part of that organization.
[SPEAKER_00]: My agents have told me this.
[SPEAKER_00]: And he was here trying to figure out what the Toli actually had taken.
[SPEAKER_00]: The agents that attacked him, unbeknownst to those agents, were up against Gouge and Karma, my agents as bodyguards.
[SPEAKER_00]: They were defeated when they tried to assassinate Lord Franck.
[SPEAKER_00]: And Franck was able to rip something from their minds.
[SPEAKER_00]: King Toli has taken possession of a very powerful ancient artifact.
[SPEAKER_00]: And I believe that artifact allows him to control turtle dragons.
[SPEAKER_00]: Our ships disappearing in the ocean are because of his control of that artifact.
[SPEAKER_00]: And that's why we've not been able to effectively fight the Kiowish fleet.
[SPEAKER_01]: Are we able to at least maneuver to Redshore and then also in the Jerley Bay area without being molested by those?
[SPEAKER_01]: In other words, is it just more out when shipping goes out to the open sea?
[SPEAKER_00]: The Dragon Isles are very close to both Redshore and Monmurg, so anything north of here...
[SPEAKER_00]: Runs the risk.
[SPEAKER_00]: Runs the risk of Kane Toli and these dragons.
[SPEAKER_00]: Jerley Bay seems to be unmolested, but that's because the Toli...
[SPEAKER_00]: They control Jerley Bay, and that's their main thoroughfare.
[SPEAKER_00]: So their access to the Amedeo jungle has not been affected in the least.
[SPEAKER_01]: Do you believe that are the Toli capable of doing a direct assault on Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely not.
[SPEAKER_00]: Our defenses are impenetrable to their armies.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's no way that even Keoland's armies, which are significantly
[SPEAKER_00]: Would be able to attack this place.
[SPEAKER_01]: With the assistance of the sahuagin if we don't have the material?
[SPEAKER_00]: There is no assistance from the sahuagin.
[SPEAKER_00]: I believe that the sahuagin just go and eat where they can.
[SPEAKER_00]: Fair enough.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, they're rabid beasts being sucked on.
[SPEAKER_00]: They just add to the chaos.
[SPEAKER_00]: Basically, the Toli are doing this to disrupt us.
[SPEAKER_00]: But you can bet they don't wish to see the sahuagin
[SPEAKER_00]: When, in this situation, then again they have the ability to produce the yellow substance themselves.
[SPEAKER_01]: So research the substance and find out if it was, you know, if it's diminished capacity, if it's been thwarted by, or you know, any other...
[SPEAKER_00]: Figure out what caused it not to work effectively.
[SPEAKER_01]: Try to discover if, with Lord Fairwind, say that again, what was it about him?
[SPEAKER_00]: Where he stored his perils, if possible.
[SPEAKER_01]: And help Paul in this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Because that's the assignment Gian is going to give him mainly.
[SPEAKER_01]: And also try to instruct Paul on... Or at least assess his capabilities with rudimentary measure.
[SPEAKER_00]: To learning arcane matters, yes, exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: Few people know who Paul's father was.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've been mildly curious, but if it's a state secret, I don't need it.
[SPEAKER_00]: His father was brilliant.
[SPEAKER_00]: And from what Gian has told me, and from my interactions with the lad, he definitely possesses very capable intelligence.
[SPEAKER_00]: His father's mother is incredibly intelligent and is
[SPEAKER_01]: Magical herself.
[SPEAKER_01]: Did he suffer a hideous defacing injury, or is he just shy?
[SPEAKER_01]: If I don't need to know.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just curious if I'll always relate to him through a mask.
[SPEAKER_00]: You should.
[SPEAKER_00]: And to be honest, his disfigurement has nothing to do with disease.
[SPEAKER_00]: He was burned horribly and he was burned horribly as a young child as a result of one of his father's experiments.
[SPEAKER_00]: Magic?
[SPEAKER_00]: Magical.
[SPEAKER_01]: Definitely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Those things.
[SPEAKER_01]: That's what you have.
[SPEAKER_01]: So the artifact.
[SPEAKER_01]: Try to do some research still on the artifact.
[SPEAKER_01]: What the item is that they're using to control, or at least its nature.
[SPEAKER_01]: The yellow substance and where Lord Fairwind stashed his containers.
[SPEAKER_00]: Help Paul develop a network of spies.
[SPEAKER_00]: Help Paul with his magical studies and see what he's capable of and report back to me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do not be blinded.
[SPEAKER_00]: By Prince John's loyalties in this.
[SPEAKER_01]: His loyalties aren't mine.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you're talking about his relationship with Fairwood...
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm talking about his relationship with everyone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_00]: These are dangerous times, and to be honest with you, I don't fully trust Prince John's judgment.
[SPEAKER_00]: Suspect everyone.
[SPEAKER_00]: Exactly.
[SPEAKER_00]: That ship would not have been taken by the sahuagin if I had had my way with it.
[SPEAKER_00]: There would have been a barrel of our own on board.
[SPEAKER_00]: I think Prince John's eyes are being opened slowly, but for us to survive, they need to open much quicker than they are.
[SPEAKER_00]: But do not let on to Paul about this.
[SPEAKER_00]: Of course.
[SPEAKER_01]: I have in mind
[SPEAKER_01]: Paul commanded the contingent of 20 marines, the only ones to survive from that ship.
[SPEAKER_01]: Would you be able to let me know their names and if they get repositioned back into Monmurg or reassigned back into Monmurg?
[SPEAKER_01]: If they stay on the helm, only in the sense of the network that you were talking about, they would be familiar with both myself and with Paul and I think maybe have some sense of owing their survival?
[SPEAKER_00]: I can give you the name of the commander and he can talk to the men if you wish to.
[SPEAKER_01]: Just to have, well, I would have Paul talk to the men, but yes, if you want him to develop a network.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_01]: Helping people survive the sahuagin attack is three good grounds.
[SPEAKER_00]: And of course there's money for bribes and such.
[SPEAKER_00]: In fact, that's probably the only thing we have bundles up right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, that's what I was going to say also, is that those men, if they have families especially, would probably appreciate being able to
[SPEAKER_00]: Unfortunately, food is something we don't have an abundance of right now.
[SPEAKER_00]: Anyway, I'm being informed that Gouge is going to come in and speak with me soon.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm sure you have things for him and his crew to do.
[SPEAKER_00]: Absolutely.
[SPEAKER_00]: My tenant will take you back up the way you came.
[SPEAKER_00]: Please use my residence to travel and collect your stuff in the foreign district, if you like.
[SPEAKER_01]: Will there be keys to that?
[SPEAKER_01]: When will the tower be made available?
[SPEAKER_00]: Tomorrow.
[SPEAKER_00]: Come back to my residence tomorrow and I'll make sure you have it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Thank you for your wine.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay, so you walk out.